At the beginning of the lesson we
identified NP as those problems for
which an answer can be
verified in polynomial time.
Remember how easy it was to check
that a clique was a clique?
In the more formal treatment however,
we identified NP as those languages
recognized by non-deterministic
Turing machines in polynomial time.
Now we get to see why
these mean the same thing.
To get some intuition,
we'll revisit the example of
finding a clique of size four.
We already discussed how a clique
of size four is easy to verify.
But how easy is it to find with
a non-deterministic machine?
The key is to use the non-determinism
to create a branch of computation for
each subset of size four.
And then use our verification strategy
to decide whether any of those
subsets correspond to a clique.
Remember, that if any sequence
of configuration accepts,
then the non-deterministic
machine accepts.
One branch of computation
might choose these four, and
then reject, because it's not a clique.
Another branch of computation might
choose these four, and also reject.
But one branch will choose the correct
subset, and this will accept.
And that's all we need.
If one branch accepts,
then the whole non-deterministic
machine does as it should.
There is this clique of size four here.